[Applause]
it's great to see so many new faces from
the trouble world and world trouble
faces to having spent the last night in
it I also didn't run you guys back to
the best nights to cover the last four
months pleasure I want to start with a
little bit of background as to
specifically why I'm here today because
as you may know I'm not a tourism or
business expert but through my troubles
I have observed the unique relationship
between community and environment and
resist something alarming there wasn't
this symbiosis or connection that we
need to be wanting to understand why I'm
one of those people watching enough
thoughtful and I want to use it to
tackle hard problems in the hope of
finding solutions like the years I've
had the distinct privilege of working
around the globe representing my mother
the Queen throughout the Commonwealth
and beyond this role has given me a
unique perspective on the issues the
world faces and an opportunity to be a
diverse range of communities to hear
them describe their problems as well as
their ideas for solutions the years I've
been listening and learning
I never presume to have all the answers
but I do feel impassioned to help in any
way that I can sometimes that means
connecting people and making them aware
of the idea that I've seen succeed you
know
places other times it means bringing
your problem home and working it through
with true experts who have dedicated
their lives to protecting our planet or
with inferential people who can give
time and/or money in the hallways one
thing I've learned however again and
again is that often times the best
solution comes from within from the
local community members who live and
breathe it every day there is one moment
that stands out in my memory from a trip
I made back in 2012 while representing
my grandmother in the cafeteria as I
walked to the boats to observe a coral
reef in planting project and a
seven-year-old come to me took my shirt
and say with such conviction because of
your country and I thought my country's
coral reef is dying
this boy despite his age and touched on
a powerful truth he already understood
the environmental damage caused to the
wreath was created by the actions of
people outside of his company and he was
absolutely spot-on his words deeply
affected me because they revealed the
full impact earth science can have on a
community without even realizing it at
the time his comment did not register as
tourism related but it did make me want
to understand better the relationship
between both of us that travel and
places to visit and perhaps not just
when we travel that in our everyday
actions and habits to some problems are
fine invisible others are not the latter
are perhaps either more damaging as out
of sight out of mind creeps in as Travis
we often don't see the long-term impact
we have on our destination unless
perhaps we revisit the same
after seeing and experiencing the
degradation of a few of my favorite
places
we're not try a set so depleted and
communities left feeling defeated I knew
something had to be done over the last
ten years as I have developed my work in
conservation but I've learned so much in
experiences I've had and the people that
I've met in places like Botswana and the
Caribbean in the palm and New Zealand
what is clear across this vast landscape
is in our world faces environmental
challenges of unprecedented scope and
scale from deforestation and the loss of
biodiversity to ocean plastics and
function the problems can sometimes seem
too big to fit these human pose
challenges often need a giant system
shift to make a significant amount of
impact and that is what this pump is
going to try and do but just because it
is such a massive undertaking doesn't
mean we can delay our pot sometimes the
scale of the conservation racism feels
overwhelming and then individual actions
conflict the difference I've certainly
thought that but I've learned that we
cannot dismiss the idea of trying to do
something just because we can't do
everything we can all do better and
while no one is perfect we all have a
responsibility for our own individual
impact the question is what we do to
balance it out so today after two years
of behind-the-scenes conversations and
planning we're going to stop in tourism
industry so that's first to find the
problem sometimes when we appreciate the
world's beauty we Clayton its fragility
it's a paradise but in our enthusiasm we
can
please strain on the natural wonders we
travel to see as well as the communities
they're called motivate us hope in 2000
the number of trips taken by people
around the world has more than doubled
we will reach 1.8 billion international
trips by 2030 doubling the number of
trips meant annually a lot of 20 years
the negative impacts of mass tourism and
unsustainable tourism are increasingly
in the news thanks to the reporting of
many of you in this room you've seen it
I've seen it and here we are in the city
of Amsterdam which joins a growing list
of places like Venice and Barcelona that
have become overwhelmed by crowds maya
bay in thailand which was made famous by
the film the beach has been besieged
that it's something so besieged that its
reefs have died
it's bioluminescent waters of film it's
trashed and its baby will be closed to
tourists at least 21 then there's Nepal
which recently had to remove
approximately 12 tonnes of waste the
climbers left on the slopes of Mount
Everest and throughout high tourism
spots in Africa Safari vehicle traffic
jams are beginning to outnumber the very
wildlife the travelers hope to see them
in their natural habitats as tourism
inevitably increases in the years ahead
its dangers will increase accordingly
and this worries me as I'm sure it does
to me too but the silver lining is that
this grave threat is also a great image
we have the opportunity to address this
tourism paradox and turn one of the
world's biggest problems
is one of its greatest solutions tourism
can be a source of opportunity for
communities that might not otherwise
find it tourism can strengthen the local
economy and tourism drives improvements
in the quality of life for so many in
some cases
it is all they have it accounts for 10%
of total global GDP and about one in ten
jobs worldwide because that will
continue to grow in the coming years
this is the scale of the opportunity
there are positive trends in the travel
industry as well seven in ten travelers
say they want more sustainable travel
options a white like a white majority
say that they want their money spent on
travel to positively impact local
communities and these are more than just
personal preferences global trends it's
estimated that by 2023 the global
sustainable tourism market will grow by
about 340 billion people are speaking up
they want to see the world but they also
want to know with all the great
souvenirs memories photos that they
leave just as much been behind they want
a paradigm shift and I believe one is
coming I believe we can and we must find
new ways to minimize the dangers and
maximize the opportunities for tourism
more and more people will travel and we
can't stop that nor would we want to
because it truly opens our minds and for
this our horizons we seek to appreciate
what is different and to find what
connects us travel expands our
understanding of the world and suddenly
brings down barriers and preconceptions
but it also offers us an escape it can
also deepen our sense of obligation to
this boring place that we come behind
when astronauts that found must adapt
from above they speak of an overview
effect a realization that our planet is
both singular and fragile and when we
travel we realize the same
and that is why we need to work together
across sectors borders cultures and
generations to Bri orientate the entire
travel industry towards sustainability
and equity into mainstream rather than
niche today I am proud to announce the
launch of a global partnership the
wanting just that it will help make
tourism work for the world it will help
strengthen communities and ecosystems
the generations to come
it will turn trouble into a catalyst the
transformative change so I am proud to
announce Thomas Thomas is a
first-of-its-kind coalition the United
from the physicists dedicated to making
trouble and an engine for sustainability
the founding fathers were all
represented here today include some of
the rulers and heavy hitters of the
global travel industry looking calm sea
trip strikes twice gotta TripAdvisor and
Visa these organizations that can really
make waves and the tide is changing
we are of course incredibly happy to
have them on board and to join in
partnership not only with one another
which is crazy easy but also every
Sussex world the foundation of my wife
and I launch in 2020 in a moment on
invite the leaders from the pottery
companies to tell you why they've agreed
to join first
I've seen so many great conservation
projects struggle not because they won
the Nobel or worthwhile but because they
didn't get by the organization could
really make a difference on day one
troubles have that Bible and we're
determining to use it over the next few
years these companies have committed to
using their global role to drive the
systemic change these companies have
direct relationships with millions of
travelers and businesses and deep
connections with countless communities
leveraging their position at the center
of travelers operators and consumers
they are perfect place to help make the
travel industry vastly more sustainable
for audience we're not just going to use
that institutional buying we're going to
use it right as we know there is no
one-size-fits-all solution to the
environmental challenges facing our
world every community of course is
different different in geography geology
and ecology different language and
culture and in government structure but
there is one way in which almost all
communities are similar they know what
they need to try if we back them with
the tools support and opportunity they
will be able to implement effective and
themselves Travis will help to provide
that support by working together with
the people on the ground telling our
efforts to all be here and measuring
impact at the community level because
communities will be at the center of
everything we do and we're not going to
be a bent the wheel by harnessing the
power of the private sector Travis will
complement some of the great work
already being done by NGOs activists
governments and multilateral
organizations across the world over the
next few years the members of Travis
will work together to create incentives
for organizations and destinations to do
right by the places spaces and animals
that we all need to protect at the same
time that we make consumers aware of
more off the beaten track places to
share the impacts as well as the
benefits with local communities we know
that it can be hugely overwhelming out
there as we are inundated with
information varying standards and data
but the role of Travis is the simplified
management to make travel choices easier
and better
and lastly returning to the point I made
a moment ago
Travis will work to make sure that
tourism substantially contribute to the
long-term interests of communities who
in turn will be incentivized to
safeguard those destinations as it
stands in rural communities especially
in developing countries the overwhelming
majority of money spent by tourists
links away before he committed the
lasting impact we have to change that if
conducting responsibly tourism can
benefit communities for generations even
those schools create jobs strengthen
safety
and you create a virtuous cycle as
communities protect what further promote
tourism sustainability and economic
stability we believe of two sides at the
same point after all healthy ecosystems
of a life like all of us by promoting
and accepted izing sustainable
decision-making by helping us as
consumers stay better informed and by
empowering communities travelers will
strive to change of travel industry and
the world
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]